did you hear what Pinterest just said
Pinterest just said uh last week I think
Pinterest will now take down content
spreading climate change misinformation
this is uh let me go to what story what
page is that on it's on page three I'll
read this to you and then I'll get you a
commentary on everything we just
discussed right now so uh uh uh
Pinterest will take down uh content
spreading climate change misinformation
uh uh the announcement shows Pinterest
known for providing a space to share
ideas about clothing food and Furniture
is also getting into sustainability the
company is launching a preemptive
striking as climate change
misinformation becoming the first social
media Network to prohibit users from
sharing inaccurate data about climate
change the site will now use a
combination of Automation and human
review to find misinformation remove it
and replace it with accurate articles
about climate change yeah well my only
first comment is I can't believe they
weren't doing that already I just
thought I assume they all were It's just
sad because YouTube just recently
demonetized any climate Skeptics from
even getting anything not that that
didn't affect me but the same thing
everyone cheering on what they did for
Russia right after the invasion into
Ukraine where banking government
corporations all got together and
immediately just went after and
essentially shut it same thing that
Trudeau did to the uh truckers in Canada
be very afraid because they can use that
directly back on someone if you hold
anti-covet views if you hold
anti-climate views anti you know viral
scare views this is all part essentially
you know Davos crowd Klaus Schwab small
narrow window to reset our world
disinformation control of it is probably
the one of the most important things a
lot of their training sessions for
covert they talked about shutting down
the internet to stop misinformation so
I'm sure Pinterest probably has a covert
policy very similar and these are just
the first steps they're going to keep
going and any I almost said idiot but
any person out there who says so private
company they should be able to do what
they want nothing's private anymore big
big Tech censorship is government
censorship when the White House gives
issues lists of names for big Tech
corporations to censor and then they
follow suit and do it this is no longer
private companies so that's where I get
I get really angry with a lot of the
people on the
libertarian conservative who just think
oh this is this is their this is their
choice they can do it I don't know the
way to fight it is I don't think Elon
Musk is buying Twitter by the way
everything I'm seeing is I think he's
looking for an out he's saying it's full
of bots and these the whole deal is on
hold I have a feeling he's gonna walk
from this I think he just probably
doesn't want the hassle and I think in
the long-term interest just personally
to him it would probably destroy Tesla
if he did what he's talking about doing
at Twitter they're the establishments
pet company they will destroy that
company no matter what he's done on
climate no matter how popular he's been
they will get him and they have the
power to do that even to the world's
wealthiest man they will dismantle him I
I don't think it's a good move if he
doesn't if he backs out of it well he's
looking for a way I know he is I know
what he's doing because the whole 120
million dollars that you know they're
they're trying to say because you waited
a few days you save yourself this much
money by doing that in the now uh
they're they're trying to investigate
him so obviously the one thing that's
obvious forget about the fact that
whether he wants to buy it or not no one
on the left wants him to bite nobody
yeah no even yesterday did you see what
the Twitter CEO of Twitter tweeted
yesterday and how Elon Musk reacted to
it so yesterday the CEO Twitter put out
how to address the uh fight off all the
Bots
[Music]
and he wrote out a series of tweets uh
and Elon Musk so he says let's talk
about spam and let's do it with the
benefit of data facts and context okay
and he explains it in this 10-part tweet
or 15-part tweet that he puts and then
on the bottom what does uh how does Elon
Musk respond to it with a go go up go up
go to replies now go all the way up and
go to replies write their second one
that says replies and zoom in a little
bit because we can't see anything zoom
in a little bit okay keep going keep
going keep going and yeah there you go
move it this is how you responds there
not that one keep going you have to see
what he responds with what emoji there
it is right there okay so process
unfortunately we don't believe that San
Antonio so the part about uh the the
Bots Elon Musk responds with a what
emoji is that
emoji okay a poop emoji that's
essentially if he buys a company that's
a CEO but he responds with a poop emoji
I don't think it's a good move for musk
to back out I don't think it's a good
move for musk to back out he must he I
just read a whole Alex Berenson did a
thing he's Alex Berenson thinks the
deal's over it's not gonna happen I
don't know I
he was probably looking at a collapse of
his whole Enterprise possibly I mean
there they would be ruthless and going
after him I mean he could lose they're
going to be ruthless no matter what with
them well even now but less so now
because if he backs down I think I I I'm
I it appears to me he's looking for
every out but I don't know if he'll get
it out we'll see because now I think
Twitter's suing him for the original
deal it's it's getting messy but I I
hope Twitter
actually forces him to buy it okay I
hope they do okay because so too the
calls I'm getting the calls I'm getting
is I'm getting calls and I'm getting on
you know Morgan Stanley's leading this
whole thing Goldman and symbol but it's
really Morgan Stanley's deal and they're
he's looking for guys to come in this is
what up the calls I've been on rounds of
100 million cash because he wants to you
know you know leverage some of the folks
to get in as well but you don't get to
say anything but I hope the deal goes
through I think it's going to be a very
um he may if he buys Twitter he may be
the most influential man in the world
because he's gonna use his voice if he
buys it if he doesn't buy it
uh and he's smart enough to know how to
get out of it if there's anybody smart
enough to get out of a deal it's
probably a guy named Elon Musk let me
ask you about you're saying he's
basically looking for an off-ramp to get
out of the deal it's what it seems like
to me because he's talking about these
Bots it looks like the port of
contention is is the are these Bots and
these fake accounts I've seen is that
really what he's worried about or is
that is there a bigger problem I think
he's I think he's just I think he's I
think all his investors all his Partners
everyone is telling him this is the end
of Tesla and it very well I mean I don't
put anything past them you know in terms
of what I say them I mean the
establishment it'll be the end of Tesla
why if he goes through Twitter I just
think that they're going to do
everything they can in terms of
government contracts regulations support
could affect his space and this Rises
because a lot of his the whole world has
been okay so that will between
government and private that's exactly
why taking money from the government is
the is not a freaking good move because
they eventually strong Army like like
he's talking about did you get that
SpaceX would you think they'll
eventually say if you do this here's
what we're gonna do because we fed you
this that's exactly why the nationalized
system doesn't work exactly that's
exactly why that doesn't work punishes
individuality any dissent you have to
tow the party line on everything same
thing we saw on every I mean everything
from climate covered
um I was selling health insurance
Obamacare comes out and all these guys
in L.A were like oh my God I'm still
Obamacare let me tell you I just sold
100 policies as a pat we're making money
so much money man you got to get in I'm
like yeah bro there's one person I don't
compete with and that's the government
I'm out I left I'm like I'm not touching
health insurance at all they forced
everybody to use three or five different
insurance companies every year I saw my
premium going up for what I have to pay
for as an employer I'm like yeah I'm not
competing with you guys you're right you
win Obama you win I'm out we'll go to a
different industry that you're not going
to be involved so what's the correlation
there or the lesson there with Elon Musk
and what he's doing with Tesla and
potentially with Twitter the correlation
is
ah man let's look I'm watching you're
watching this Amber Heard and uh Johnny
Depp what a sweetheart of a girl she is
right just listen to her the more I
watch her like they showed a recording
yesterday of how she's like you know the
attorney says do you know why Johnny
doesn't look at your eyes do you know by
the way do you have to use the restroom
so judge do you know why Johnny doesn't
look at your eyes and he's like no do
you look at Johnny's eyes in court I do
does he look at you no do you know why I
don't know you should know I don't know
then she plays the recording and it's a
recording of Johnny and Amber and she's
like please stop touching me he's like
come on please I just want it one more
time I want to hug you because I I know
I'm sorry I was like stop touching me
says you will never
see these eyes look at you ever again
never you hear in the recording Johnny
got to a point that I will never can you
imagine a loved one telling you I will
never make eye contact because you know
love is the eye contact I will never
look at you ever again right you've seen
all these things being revealed about
where it's at and how power structure
and manipulation when somebody gets a
hold of you dude Amber Heard is a small
government controlling a guy that she
almost ruined his life because he came
out and said this guy beat me you know
it was a question that the lawyer asked
I love the question says hey does Johnny
always wear these rings as long as I
know he always has these rings on is it
fair to say these are not small Rings no
is it fair to say he wears very big gory
Rings you know not gory Rings like just
gaudy Rings yeah yes has he always for
as long as I know he's always warned us
he says okay great this is the picture
you showed that he hits you
you what would happen if he hits you
with these Rings you're like what a
freaking great point if he has hit you
as many times as you claim he's hit you
how come you don't have any scars for
him from from these Rings this guy this
girl ruined the guy's life for what she
did and he comes out it's so weird can
you imagine a man saying yeah I'm suing
my wife for domestic violence yeah yeah
that's your emasculated right yeah
anyways the government yeah is doing to
musk what potentially Amber Heard did to
Johnny and I hope musk responds like
Johnny did I hope musk responds like
Johnny did because somebody has to stop
the bullying and if that is really what
is going on behind closed doors if there
is a guy that can do that it's this
crazy guy it's him and uh that doesn't
mean they're not gonna stop coming after
you that doesn't mean they're not going
to stop playing games with them that
doesn't mean they're not going to stop
trying to get SEC taxes they're going to
find some [ __ ] on this guy right that if
they want to do it but the alternative
is what you're officially owned by the
government you officially have to get a
tattoo that says I'm government owned
property so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]